hello party people Oh welcome to be
honest trailer commentaries for Captain
Marvel she's a hero taking pollution
down to zero
I'm getting my captain's mixed up but
that's Joe Danielle Dan guys thanks and
crunch aah
cool is very cool it was a film we all
watched and enjoyed to various extents
it happened we saw it we wrote about it
the second time for me I think yeah who
feels the most strongly about Captain
Marvel here at this table which way in
what direction any direct pick a
direction I I'm not a huge fan I don't
hate it and I love it it's it's ok I
thought the same way this is like when I
walked out of like ant-man and the wasp
and maybe ant-man and I will not accept
ant-man slander on this here half-circle
table but yes but I see what I see your
point I walked out of it like a
phase-one like a Thor for me yeah I
didn't walk out of it like I'm going to
think about that for weeks like because
sometimes you walk out of a Marvel movie
you're like man like when it's all did
you shoot me up man and this was this
was not that but it was also not at the
bottom for me yeah i define a factor for
me was that i even in the movies that I
enjoyed less than I enjoyed Captain
Marvel overall I felt I connected with
the characters more and other than I
loved my Koran bow and um she was the
best character in the movie and like ten
minutes of screen time mmm I just didn't
connect to Captain Marvel in any
meaningful way and I think this Bing
MMN I think it was a maybe a bit of a
misstep and how they chose to
characterize her the amnesia is a little
bit of a hump okay I hate amnesia as a
main character condition whether it's
Jason Bourne
when Captain Marvel the entire Kingdom
Hearts franchise Jackie Chan in Who am I
it's it really gives you nothing to do
yeah character wise because you don't
know who you are can't make any
decisions as an actor because you don't
know what those would be
yeah well but in a screenplay where you
don't know who the character actually is
and like Jason Bourne has amnesia but it
I think it helps because you you as a
viewer don't know who he really is like
you know that he's a spy but you don't
like know much about his life tomorrow
scouting amnesia and she's like I don't
know who I am and as a viewer you're
like I know who you are you're Captain
Marvel yeah right yeah becomes something
that you already know that they yeah
unless it's of the year you know the
last Targaryen and it doesn't end up
mattering anyways the answer is never
going to satisfy you for who am i cuz I
remember the Bourne movies were like his
name is like duds and Pudwill from
Arkansas okay I hope he had a wonderful
child yeah and Captain Marvel we make
the point the trailer is like who she
found out that she was is almost
identical to who she was yeah she's a
flying soldier like military snarky
person yeah hot shot good everson all
the same you know real horses in the
pasture she's like the same person but
her name is Carol yes big deal she gets
a full last name you guys yeah so
despite our muted reactions at this
table we must be wrong because the
conversation around this movie was best
movie ever worst movie ever as it so
often is and god I guess if I had to
pick I'd say best movie ever because it
wasn't the worst movie ever but also it
wasn't the best movie ever and it said
that that has to be how we classify
things look what the ladies have a
mediocre one too we've earned it yes
I'm just a middle-of-the-road middleback
movie yeah it was a Marvel movie like
they're they're not terrible this one
didn't blow my mind like that's fine
yeah it's starting to be a
self-fulfilling prophecy anytime
someone's like oh it has a Captain
Marvel type reaction like negative
reactions like oh it's like you're
setting the terms for what you're
getting mad at just let it be what it is
which is that was fine yeah but you
built the monster now you have to be out
the muscle like you but you put you
spend all that money on duct tape at
Home Depot building up that month you
did that but yeah I do think controversy
definitely drives more people to see a
movie like this then they would if it
just went completely unremarked on and
it would Lander and fill it with
mannequins and cardboard cut-out being
because we live in a crazy sphere of
fire and insanity and not just cuz the
AC is broken we also forget that roughly
94 percent of the movie-going audience
has no idea what's happening as far as
like people on the internet are angry
yeah well but I think that there's a
subset of people like where it becomes
like an identity marker that you went to
support it like I only saw Beauty and
the Beast because I heard whose guest on
Sprint oh well I heard Lefou was gonna
just like totally to make that a big
deal before the movie yes do you think
it might be a little like calculated on
Disney or not calculated Disney's part
but I think they're like oh no the worst
people in the world don't get mad at her
movie I don't think they run from it
yeah
revealing the beast the amount that they
hyped that up I thought guests are I
thought uh Lefou was gonna bang the
beast like that's what I was waiting
guys this is gonna be groundbreaking and
yeah I thought they're gonna make the
beast with two backs yeah mares helping
but no I would not have noticed it and I
stated condition you to be like cuz like
it wasn't just like oh yeah we threw a
little moment in there that we thought
was very inclusive well what it was I
think it the drugs is like Lefou has an
exclusively gay moment exclusively if it
was like some adjectives and gay it was
like like well they kind of did it with
endgame to where it was like the gayest
character in the MCU of all time and
then whereas that could have just been
like a nice like right on guys I was
like oh was that the okay that was the
man a director cameo said he had a
boyfriend all right I was yeah yeah cuz
when they hike it up like that you're
like Hawkeye is gonna be like my wife's
gone no finally that's what he said
those Condon said that there's an
exclusively gay moment what some like
what does that even mean exclusively gay
like does it do does it did they like
saturate it soul I can only show he's in
the ocular cavity like to dig up like a
scanner that like only shows part of the
movie those grades are I don't get it
as soon as you see it at just rainbow
flashes above your eyes people so that's
so worked up over it and then MV maybe
you're right maybe Disney was just like
like planted that to get a little free
pub yeah out there a little extra word
on the street of abusing the beast but I
think you get to the end this will get
Hannity shaken yeah no I think it's
largely a marketing not largely a
marketing tactic but I don't like you
said I don't think they right now right
in front they like no oh controversy oh
there's a we're part of a culture war I
guess you're gonna have to see the movie
to pick a side we're all rubes okay
let's watch a trailer and we'll talk
more during it oh yes by the way delete
seats
from mark Oh so Stanley cameos it's not
fair you're gonna make me cry we haven't
even started yet
Marvel is taking it back to the First
Avenger no not that one this Avenger
before are the new ones like and man
well not that a man before Black Panther
at least well after two chocolate was
Black Panther but before T'Challa right
look I don't know it's it's the nineties
okay she's the nineties one supposed
there was a I guess Nick Farah was
already working on a superhero team but
he hadn't called it the Avengers yet he
had an idea sounded like this encounter
inspired him to think of it a team a
team and then hurt the name on her jet
yeah he Avengers he started that
document that morning like clip he
popped up and it was like I see you're
trying to make a superhero attempt right
yeah but an Avenger was just her
callsign because like Nick Fury's
interactions with hers more like she's
like a she ended up the movie is like a
refugee guide for the scroll for this
girl yes yeah she wasn't like no it was
her on it and it's her maverick yeah
yeah I'm glad that instead of I'm glad
that instead of encounter and Carol he
wasn't just like watching Top Gun that
movie and then they were just called the
cougar initiative yeah
[Music]
gesture no jester's dead let's keep
making them Wolf Man Charlie she wasn't
a pilot named volleyball scene over and
over thank you go Captain Marvel journey
to holla of spaceship literally becomes
part in my ass to recover her true
identity a snarky flying soldier without
amnesia just don't tell her how to feel
emotional isn't a female dangerous war
warrior and emotion you struggle with
your emotions do not let your emotions
override your judgment and you keep your
emotions in check long enough to take me
on because this hotshot pilot likely
keep it in neutral and get to the bottom
of the spheres together okay
it's lingering shot we had some internal
debate about this and there was I think
that there are readings of her
performance that are more charitable to
what's happening and less charitable to
what's happening yeah I was more
charitable I this movie did not do her
any favors as an actor like you hired
brie Larson you know that she's not like
a hey like razzmatazz like I'm Robert
Downey jr. I'm all over the place or
like a Johnny Depp swagger II like she's
a very like quiet sort of understated
actor and they surrounded her with an
understated plot up with an understated
amnesiac character and like the editing
is weird around some of those
understanded moments like the countdown
is very fair unlike mm-hmm you know yeah
I mean look I think that there is a
super valid point to make where it's
like oh guys tell women they're too
emotional all the time to control them
that said in the movie I think the movie
really wants you to think she's a
hothead like the movie really is is
putting a lot of stock in the fact that
she's a wild card and she's like flying
too close to the edge but she just isn't
yeah she's pretty chill except for like
that time when she was a kid and she
somehow did I don't know putting some
nas I'm like sure to the Michael Bogart
and that's one where it's like oh yeah
there it is like there's the there's
heard having the speed and defying
people and that's how I got it but
that's really I feel I could be wrong
one of the only real big hothead moment
today wasn't the tower that's my problem
it's the difference between the the
message of the movie and the execution
of it which is like I like that message
which is the idea and it ties into the
real world of just like yes this idea
that women are too emotional they can't
do their you know but that's what often
is is it can be a strength and it's just
written off as a weakness like that is
that's a very good message what's the
execution of it it's the fact that there
is there is at that moment like III
think that if they had done this event
that
raid scene where they go onto the planet
to rescue the people they turn out to be
Scrolls but if there's a moment where
Carol does lose control or duh you know
like she's Oliver meant let's say she
realizes that these that she sees
something in the scrolls that says that
they may not be what they are it she's
like stop wait don't do this and and
that gets someone on the team hurt that
gives them the omission to see like see
what you did because you followed your
emotions you got someone hurt and it
gives her a reason to not do that but in
actuality because of the compassion that
she saw because she was as it turns out
actually trying to stop them from doing
something that ties in more to the theme
of that the emotional like they'd added
that keeping in touch with that it's
important for her and that's what makes
her a hero you could have its they were
telling you that but they weren't doing
that in in the movie at all that was my
disconnect was like I get the the like
the societal undertone of that message
but never in the execution of that movie
to me did they do that with the
character and that was my problem with
it it just was dissonant yes yeah yeah I
don't want everything add to that okay
bring the kree's not alone like every
Marvel hero she needs someone to smirk
at like yawn wrong
her problematic Yoda Maria Rambo her
Marvel issued black friend okay did they
tiptoe around the fact that they were a
couple or take it right what's that just
reading too far into that queer queer
Twitter got a lot ideas okay I have said
this before if you gain that's why with
these things it's so funny because I
think they recognize that if you give us
a little Weald will do all of the leaps
and logic and all of the work for you
because we get so little that they can
say mochi is Thor's adopted brother he's
fine
you know about that you know well we
have an exclusively game moment if you
promise us a game moment we're gonna get
really really super hyped and excited
for it but if you can queerbait us just
a little bit without telling us and our
friends will take it everywhere because
someone posted on Twitter I saw this I
forget who tweeted it um I want to say
was Marvel where it's like you know I'll
watch these two best friends fly and all
of the comments are just friends yeah
the whole thing with like the bull cut
and then like they're they're just like
she calls her like aunt Carol and like
they spend a lot of time together like
real deep connection never just
coworkers never felt the same way when
like yeah your aunt or your cousin or
someone who you know is that well is it
like an out lesbian but you're like no
and do they have a friend
BBQ and it's like oh here's Aunt Linda
who's always here yeah do you sir friend
do you think they were worried they made
it too obvious with Steve and Bucky that
is very much that is a black folk thing
we're like if you're best friends with
someone and then you have a kid that
child is now you are now that child's
aunt and you have no no excuse I am the
aunt of a lot of children betting in a
dual role as a side as we don't really
get to know and a computer we don't
really understand the dog from the thing
in cat form
stealing the show a facially de-aged
Nick Fury and effect feel good at that
like it's never that young to run or use
a keyboard the one finger typing a lot
of us are doing that introducing
superhero teams again you've waited
years for Marvel to introduce the
scrawls thrill with the possibility that
they'll be the next big bad after Thanos
because they could be anyone from
Captain America to cute cuddly family
man
wait the scrolls are nice how do you not
make ben mendelsohn evil then Mendelson
is always evil you're so not getting
Secret Invasion oh I mean we might be
video yeah prediction though the that's
a splinter pocket of goods girls and the
music or sent to like throw people off
the scent cuz they're gonna run out of
plot lines I think they were actually
took a little time to sets up the idea
of a really like put upon group of
people that are now splintered up and
refugees and that's gonna turn some of
them wrote real mean and real angry
scrawled a spell yeah like you're not
just I actually obviously let's check on
everything else that just kind of said
because there's no one thing I would
think would be like them cuz the
Mandarin was such a big thing but the
idea that like the scrolls were like the
good guy to me like I would I guess in a
vacuum you know this would have been
that would have been the bigger deal but
there was just so much other that rates
happening like I'll check back in mid
phase volume 2 yeah
we're now now volume 2 phase 1 I'll
check in at the end of volume 2 phase 1
if this hasn't happened but like to me
they're actually instead of just being
like they're green so they're angry like
all the blue villains in volume 1 like
maybe they're actually setting up some
maybe depth and I think again the movie
was selling it as like this guy speaks
for all this girls in like we are a
peaceful people who want a home that
don't pay attention to the genocide 'el
ones so we'll see yeah if I may at the
risk of getting my Marvel fan
card revoked scrolls are my amnesia
you're not a fan like a shapeshifter
that's the least it's the cheapest least
interesting we need to make a villain
for me is just like you thought to birth
Captain America but it was me even bog
it's the Mission Impossible mask trick
many sad over like I get I get it I
understand like it works a bit so money
yeah but cinematically I'm not I'm just
not a big fan because then you can it
just seems like a way to do cheap
storytelling although maybe I don't know
I just like when there's like the
scrolls are next I'm like the big
reaction I saw after the movie were
people like well if the scrolls aren't
evil then we can't do captain or a
Secret Invasion and now none of the
actors who are leaving can be recast and
I was like how do you recast with a
shapeshifter
cuz the shapeshifter just look
impersonates that person yeah laughs
guys fair point the girls not gonna show
up as like Stephen Amell and everyone's
gonna be like Steve Rogers my god I hope
they just do like a carte blanche Iron
Man to thing where all the everyone gets
recast they all walk on stage together
and go it's me yeah by the way I'm not
saying this the the comic stuff with
scrolls isn't good I just mean movie
wise as a fan of the movies I just never
been on board of like oh great the
scrolls like I don't know dramatic
reveal if they did use it as a recasting
thing because you'd get that dramatic
moment if they find the crash scroll
ship this happened in Secret Invasion
and like the the ship opens and they see
everyone who's been a double forever but
the reviews already cast actors and
you're like is that Professor X or
Obadiah Stane it's a bald man in a suit
sitting down or can he not stand up I
don't know I mean what's it happening
give God it's ready for a blockbuster
won't take AltaVista to fight one boy
they cut it immoral to take about
Kennedy's out he's on to your gay boy so
back off trolls and go back to the mall
rats her powers don't need to be nerve
because she's not melancholy about rocky
man Owen Nikes these 90s references or
his forces the movies Nine Inch Nails
radio shack all right I'm done yeah for
all the guff we give the x-men movies
for never taking advantage of the decade
hop this was so aggressively 90s it was
pouring Ravens revenge and above my
eyeballs the neck the Nexus of
everything that I really disliked about
this movie all intersected at the no
doubt needle drop as it was to me the
worst of the nineties references
combined with the most I'm gonna hit you
in the face with a sledgehammer of the
themes of the movie like it's just hmm
should have been spiderwebs I want to
pick the most obvious choice for both of
these things that have already been
extremely overly obvious about just like
that said if anyone wants to recut that
fight for us to a letters to Cleo song
like I'm into it
what's letters to Cleo remember here and
now their one hit song
[Music]
show don't tell show don't tell yeah
sure don't go in if it was just like a
better song to fight to I don't know I
don't remember in the 90s like just
skanking around and our down pin like
times it is brutalizing it's not for us
but most most of the most popular songs
the use in this song I was a big fan of
no doubt the band yeah Magic Kingdom hmm
go ahead what happened man what's going
on what's going on Gwen Stefani making
that money in Vegas Boyden make money I
can't fault her but I just hope she
hasn't forgotten where she came from you
know Scott oh she did moment no doubt
dropped that horn line
they forgot ok enough Scott talk so get
ready for a film that's disappointing if
it's the meet and an infinity war
sandwich a solid watch if it's up
against the other Marvel origin stories
and Citizen environment Wonder Woman
look out boys at this rate lady heroes
will take over at the theater never
you were not counting group yeah I did
not count Avengers or guardians even
though I mean I think you could make the
argument that that's Peter quill and his
tree and friend and his green lady yeah
but I didn't count those um yeah it's a
it's a 61 yeah versus it was a 60 and
then mid
halfway through the day today I panic
because I realize I don't know how every
letters I won't start
I often forget that exams don't we like
a cold sweat
the captain is Miss Marple Nick furry
and scroll and clothes law in orbit true
never filled your and still has stuck in
her car windshield maria rambo car
zoom people get that one oh yeah it's
absent even at neon join the Navy yeah
but I wonder cuz I feel like that's
gonna be one where people are like why
is he just talking backwards yeah this
pissed I had well this definitely had
military integration cuz there's that
featurette we're like brie Larson just
supply some planes to play oh yeah Air
Force definitely sponsored this yeah
yeah
Air Force fun we could go to Mary Oaxaca
gun who paid DLC and the screenwriter of
what lies beneath true the fun fact I
know it's into my daughter's birthday
last time I trusted someone I lost I'm
trusting you not to eat me they're gonna
went out of his way to say trust to that
can I trust you didn't quite pay off
about abort not agree play mind it now
who cares
make it a joke and I who cares that's a
valid basis way yeah that's what he got
for trusting a cat mission
in hell that that very dark and serious
moment with Captain America that he was
thinking about the time he trusted a
flirting cat no chance first adventure
they work like some day this game is
gonna look at his own ass he looked at
his own ass somewhere in the future in
the first dimension my own ass I got
half chub know I'd be like I've looked
another man's ass before a buck and it's
like that were a very traumatic thing in
his life and then 10 years later he
turns out it was a joke no Markus and
McFeely obviously wrote that line with
the trust that perhaps the audience that
they would they would reveal that with
some with some gravitas and instead it
was a flirting cat and I need to rewatch
the first offender to make sure there's
no for sure I just I feel like if the
moment finally came and it was like
really serious and like a scroll had
been Phil Coulson the whole time and he
was like I'm not really Phil I'm Jean
Mork
there's probably no good way then don't
answer it at all it does I do have an
iPad I do here's me meeting you in the
middle Dan I do think they just should
have teased the cat going for his I
constantly through the movie and never
have it happen in the movie just nothing
but uh almost my jokes like development
setting up the hand doing hi jokes but
not with the cat like they're a doing
thing that's it was a runner like that's
I think wasn't just that it was like the
whole movie there's like a whole house
you're I'm Nick never pay it off just
run her like Ben should have been like
ow
the someone have like drops it's like a
naked gun joke I don't know
it's not what they did in a vacuum it's
how they did it earlier and then the
payoff is like my cat before so like I
have five claw marks in my leg right now
from a cat I trust me I'm very because I
picked up a cat once but I thought I
wanted to be held I never do
I'm well aware of what I got a dr. evil
mark once from a cat I've had cat eye
which is bored away from the face I
don't I'm not in the middle with you Joe
I'm firmly in my corner you've
subscribed to cat facts let's watch
tryam that blew away all expectations or
a secret failure that proved Hollywood
is full of leftist chills spending
millions to fake a hit because the idea
of a Marvel movie just being okay and
doing well isn't even a possibility
anymore I guess
10250 unless the internet was a mistake
it's a disappointment if you see it as
the meat in an infinity war sandwich but
fits perfectly alongside every Marvel
origin story not named Iron Man but what
do I know I'm just a misogynist bigot
too afraid to admit that it's great and
an SJW soy boy too scared to say that it
sucks
hey the river we didn't expect Disney
movies to heal societies and justices
that's what being mad on Twitter is for
I mean that was the road not taken'
several roads not taken basically I
think we're reacting too much to the
discourse around the movie which has
will be forgotten and is is a fraction
of a fraction of the people who actually
watch this and don't really care yeah I
leaned heavily the other way partly
because haven't felt stuck in it for
many people that reviewed Captain Marvel
we should I should create a witch this
should be survivors
you risk love just swap stories and
because mine wasn't even bad in its own
way but it was like I say cousin the
work because I didn't like it I was just
thanked for my honesty we're just stupid
cuz I'm honest about every movie because
this one time I happen to agree with a
lot of people are like oh thank you for
your they spend all that money and time
on their own duct-tape little monsters
if they built and they're like you
didn't like a movie you know the dumb
battle line got drawn like yeah people
needed this to be bad or needed it to be
great yeah yeah that's too much to ask
for a movie yeah better chicken low
fists and also if you need something to
be bad to feel good about yourself just
take a walk I don't know it's beyond the
scope of honest trailer commentaries
help you tears for beers get a cat right
girl
knocking your blaster
[Laughter]
Catman begins another YouTube
wait is this how they're gonna work in
x-men and Fantastic Four to the MCU the
thing is this dork may divorce rock like
the rest of his body it's a superhero
secret really rocked a beard yeah yes
the starring and the titles was one of
the times we finished the script I did
if you'll notice very few of those got
the full Holte because I at one point
turned around and said guys every guy
cannot send Robert forty starring and
eight titles lexical let's narrow that
and is happy to help Thank You bets he's
always happy to help
he's so generous and we can't take
advantage of it when we're getting we're
gonna use one
let's get these twelve down to let's say
three let's just send them through the
board and we'll send them a few old logo
shirts yeah times where I was just like
we have a wonderful graphics person and
Robert Holt means that we'll do
everything that we ask of them let's not
take advantage of that sweet Robert well
yeah we didn't take advantage of it but
we accidentally did too many this time
whoops
I believe that tell us we picked the
wrong ones we choose it's the wrong one
[Music]
subjective opinion yeah we gotta get
used to it
this is when we move over you know we're
gonna get even more well we don't want
it to use this too much here they're not
even ready for that one yet you know
this one J yeah yeah any final parting
shots parting thoughts Captain Marvel
I'm excited for her a line that I guess
we didn't record or make the cut is like
you know what took Thor like three
movies to come out of a show and be like
the most beloved and I see a lot of Thor
parallels with her like she's super
strong no quite I'm thinking out quite
how she fits in with everyone else yet
she's right now the strong one fill and
they'll fill in more later yeah I feel
like um if they're not snarky like they
often don't know what to do with them
like if they're not quipping you must be
trippin are you doing the download
you've gots to go um and also I really
expected her based on people's reactions
cuz I just finally saw it like two weeks
ago and I was based on although I was
waiting for her the whole movie to be
like I'm joyless but the whole like vote
like just to the that extreme just like
I know now why you cry but she's she's
got an equal smile and reaction and a
moat right to Steve Rogers like they
they smile about the same
that's a couple jokes should have some
good ones in yeah she's got some some
comments but don't tell her to smile Jim
God knows deleted scene apparently in
the movie like a blu-ray special edition
where she's just like absolutely beats
the [ __ ] head of that guy with the
motorcycle so very like what is
obviously a terminator reference yeah
yeah yeah so spring for the for the
deluxe blu-ray and come back to see us
sorry I'm cutting it off because I'm
drenched in my own sweat it's a hot one
guys but it's gonna be even hotter next
week when we do something much like this
week but bigger it's this special
occasion yeah bigger and better so you
have that to look forward to till then
suck it finger blaster
you